nick how are you doing great pom good to
see you man dude i'm super excited about
this uh
you're a professor at usc
what are you doing as a professor at usc
how do you get there yeah so let's start
let's just jump right into how are you
professor usc sure so it's actually a
funny story how it happened um
i was on you know a trading desk i was
trading treasuries other interest rate
products for a big asset manager for
several years and
the guy sitting next to me on the desk a
friend of julia's actually
uh he he's like nick
somebody asked me to guest lecture at sc
i don't want to do it really do you want
to do it
and i said sure he goes okay let me set
you up with my friend so i grab a beer
with this guy
and he said yeah i'm an adjunct
professor at usc i'm also responsible
for recruiting guest lectures for one of
the tenured professors teaching fixed
income which is my industry so i said
absolutely let's do it so i show up to
sc
i gave my first lecture on the
structural demand for 30-year treasuries
basically trying to explain to these
students that
old people need 30-year bonds because of
fixed cash flows and they cannot buy
equities because they cannot afford to
risk
the principle
and the professor loved it the next week
he invited me back for another guest
lecture five guest lectures later and i
get an email from the professor and he
says
hey i'm looking to grandfather my course
to you if you're interested in it would
you become an adjunct professor at usc
you can teach fixed income i'm looking
to get a little bit deeper into my
research he's doing things in china
things like that so i basically said
hell yeah yeah i would love to first of
all i'm a usc trojan i went there my dad
and grandfather went to usc i'm a third
generation trojan it's been in my family
for 50 years
and to be invited to be a professor at
sc was the biggest like no-brainer of my
life yeah so um what are the students
reactions when you're teaching the stuff
to they just there and they're like hey
i just gotta you know this part of the
curriculum i gotta just get through this
class or are they leaning in and super
excited yeah i think questions i think
you'll remember being back in school you
have some students that are super into
it and others that are not and i think
that's just always the way it's going to
be and i've found
both undergraduate and graduate students
that the ones that are interested are
super interested they want to learn
everything there is to know about
markets global macro
some of them are very interested in
bitcoin but
it's not part of the course that i
started teaching but the big news is
that usc uh the dean of marshall school
of business read my book layered money
last year
and he wanted to invite me to teach a
bitcoin
oriented course at usc which i worked on
for the last several months and last
month uh it became official so i'm going
to be teaching a class in january called
bitcoin and digital assets at usc
marshall school of business so when you
think of these students they're 18 to 22
you know on average how many of them are
into bitcoin crypto kind of this whole
world versus maybe they've heard about
it but they just got other [ __ ] going on
sure so i taught a i guess lectured for
a professor this semester in the risk
management uh department and the topic
was
uh
bitcoin and crypto literacy
going into this new
uh era of name image and likeness policy
at the ncaa level where now athletes are
basically able to get paid for what they
do and my approach was hey you athletes
need to be careful when you're offered
crypto because it could be totally
a nonsensical asset that you're being
offered if you're being offered crypto
first of all is it bitcoin and if it is
are you aware as to how you're going to
store that bitcoin yourself or on an
exchange and if it's not bitcoin if it's
crypto are they trying to create your
own coin for you in which i would say
please be careful and don't do that are
they trying to offer you some altcoin
and also in that case please be careful
and don't do that because you don't know
what you're gonna get so it's a it was
an attempt to teach bitcoin only and
that kind of risk management now the
students were
many of them were already aware of
the industry what's going on a few of
them there's there are about 30 students
in this class three to five of them had
clearly been trading crypto in some way
shape or form a couple of them were into
nfts and so and their their guest
lecture right before me the week before
was some nft expert from uh
uh tom brady's um i think it's called
signature right in the company autograph
i think autograph exactly thank you so
they were aware of some of these stuff
things but you know later in the lecture
i said hey how many of you know what
lightning network is zero people raise
their hand out of 30. so it gives you a
sense yes there's some awareness yes
there's some kids that are trading
many don't know about this stuff many
are just reading the headlines and there
were zero out of 30 that hadn't heard
about the lightning network which means
nobody had basically fallen down the
bitcoin rabbit hole out of out of 30
students so we are still pretty early
how many of them uh are interested in
this stuff because they want to get rich
quick versus they see some other value
to the assets or the industry yeah i i
usually see that it's very few of these
college students are interested in the
get rich quick scheme they're interested
in
what path do i take in my life and is
trading a potential you know avenue for
me but uh i think that the get rich
quick type of people are still into
sports betting there's you can kind of
tell like when they come over to bitcoin
they're trying to approach it as you
know is this an investment line that i
could go into or something like that
yeah i am uh i haven't really talked
about it too much but when i was in
college uh for a little while i started
to trade uh foreign currencies and it
was more of like intellectual curiosity
more than than anything else uh i think
i didn't have enough money to like think
i was gonna get rich um and uh
i started to get an education around
why are there certain decisions made
about currencies how what is the
relationship between the currencies all
the things that you would hopefully
learn as you were trying to
understand that market
and it feels like when i found bitcoin i
then went even further down this rabbit
hole of like bitcoin even though i have
an economics degree actually taught me
economics right i learned way more from
bitcoin than i ever did in a classroom
and so is that like a way to use bitcoin
as a tool for education but given that
you have that tool available to you
today you can teach people inside of a
classroom using this you know new
technology and it's something that they
can relate to they can understand
they're interested in and you find like
the uptake of the information is better
i think so and i i believe that
when you try to understand what bitcoin
is you have to take
the historical approach understand what
is money and then you have to understand
what is economic so bitcoin does
set the table
for a higher level of education around
financial and global macroeconomic
topics absolutely talk to me about other
assets so uh you recently wrote a post
uh about the potential death of ethereum
um explain a little bit of what the
thought process there is and kind of
what you think the probabilities are
sure so i'm a trader by nature right so
i'm a chart analyst i'm i do price study
every day and when i'm looking at the
ethereum versus bitcoin chart not the
ethereum versus the dollar chart but
specifically ethereum versus bitcoin i'm
seeing a breakdown in the chart so the
price is going lower we're below 0.06
today um
and that is off of the uh a high of you
know spot one five you know a couple
years ago so we've had lower highs made
over the course of now several years in
ethereum and it's showing a pattern that
is
mirroring the death of other altcoins
that we saw
take a boom in the last cycle and so
it's it's really a price study only
opinion here and i'll be quick to change
the opinion if the price reverses right
now the price of ethereum versus bitcoin
looks very suspect it is breaking down
it is making new lows
and it has made
lower highs over the course now of four
years when you think about uh that type
of analysis i think it's important to
caveat you're just looking at a price
chart this is an only price and listen
it is only a price analysis that i'm
doing with ethereum now
you could say the same thing about
bitcoin when i got into bitcoin it was
because the price analysis told me this
is an exponential trend that is
uh is
live and right in front of us and so i
got involved then i started to
learn more and more about bitcoin and
then i finally decided to purchase
bitcoin once once i believed that i had
married
the long thesis on the chart with the
long thesis of the fundamentals i did
that and then i purchased it so when
looking at ethereum i'm not
factoring in the fundamentals of the
network
or their potential switch away from
proof of work but i do believe that the
price represents all the information
that is available in the market and so
maybe it is that the traders that are
viewing the future of ethereum are
viewing it unfavorable unfavorably and
that's why the price is declining but i
lead with price i always have
and um it it hasn't led me wrong because
when you think that price is truth if
the price declines or reverses in a way
that goes against what you thought you
have to alter your
perspective you can't just be sitting on
your positions forever and so like for
example if bitcoin were to go
materially below 19500
we're gonna have to take a look at this
asset what has ha why is it broken down
below the last all-time high of 2017
five years later with all this growth
the growth of the network
until then the long thesis is sound in
bitcoin but yeah in the below 20 000
we're gonna have to take a look at it
when you start to look at uh these
assets how much of uh price has a
marketing department i i think about
that a lot right like bitcoin is a
decentralized entity there is no ceo
there's no board of directors there's no
marketing team etc uh
the
price as you described brought you in
and then you learned about bitcoin you
learned about a lot of the stuff and
then you became kind of a long-term uh
uh participant in the market
is that what we should expect everyone
to come through uh from like a funnel
standpoint is price ends up being the
thing that attracts them and then they
kind of go down the rabbit hole get
converted into what i think people would
describe as a bitcoiner in the united
states yes okay you know it's it's it is
likely that
the price is what attracts people the
most in this country um
we have a country of entrepreneurs
and
a spirit of innovation in this country
and when you see something accelerating
in price
it draws attention but if we go to
different parts of the world latin
america and africa where the currency
regimes are disasters
they're not looking at price they're
looking at does it work
does it maintain value versus my own
currency which the answer is yes you
know when you're looking at turkey or
argentina something like that
so
we we do have to be conscious that
in different parts of the world the
reason to get involved in bitcoin is
different right i
let's cite gladstein's book title check
your financial privilege
in we do have privilege in this country
and it doesn't exist in a lot of parts
of the world and so we have to put our
feet in their shoes to think about why
they might be involved in bitcoin so i
have an argentinian friend
and
i i've known him since 2012.
what he communicates to me is that the
culture in argentina of understanding
bitcoin is at another level versus the
western world because they're intimately
aware of currency collapse
hyperinflation and the things that we
tout as bitcoiners as
you know attractive things about the
network and the asset
but
are we using bitcoin as americans to
escape
uh a currency collapse
not immediately right that might be part
of your thesis over the next 10 20 years
you might even think it's coming over
the next two years in which i'd say
you're wrong about that the dollar's not
collapsing in two years
but
it's not the reason that americans are
getting involved is imminent currency
this threat is not imminent in the
united states whereas in other countries
argentina i think it's got 50 or more
you know annual inflation right and the
threat is present in the united states i
think that's why a lot of see i found
bitcoin through understanding the fed
and monetary policy and how it worked
not not after that's my that's my
background is studying the fed and
trading rates so when i look at
the
monetary situation the fiscal situation
in the united states i see something
unsustainable over a long period i also
see something that's broken
but i don't see something that's
collapsing today what's broken
the dollar is broken because
the fed
no longer is able to control
the issuance of the dollar in any way
first of all the dollar is issued by
commercial banks mostly in this country
as well as in the euro dollar system
which is
dollars issued outside of the federal
reserve banking system so you have
call it 15 trillion dollars
of
dollars created outside the fed system
that they weren't aware of for most of
the beginning of it and then when it
broke in 2007
in august to 2007 when libor and fed
funds separated what we saw is that the
euro dollar system has a risk that is
materially different than the onshore
dollar system the fed recognized that
and they put a swap line on with the ecb
in december 2007 like four months after
the system broke and they've exercised
that swap line in 08 09 during the pigs
crisis
um during the pandemic etc so the dollar
system is broken because the dollar
exists in all these different forms and
the fed has basically had to say we will
bail out the different forms even though
we never approved of them that's a
broken system
explain swap lines a little bit okay so
when the ecb the european central bank
has banks in its jurisdiction that have
issued dollar deposits to their
customers let's just put it on deutsche
bank
so let's say deutsche bank has customers
that have dollar deposits and then
deutsche bank is going through some
trouble they need dollar liquidity the
market says no we're not going to lend
you dollars euro dollar market uh you're
shut off from it so where is deutsche
bank gonna get the dollars
to stay liquid on their dollar balance
sheet
they're gonna get them from the ecb not
from the fed because the they're in
germany so they go to the ecb and they
say hey ecb can we borrow dollars
the ecb says okay but we don't have
dollars we're europe
so
they print euros
and then they post them as collateral to
the fed
and then the fed lends dollars to the
ecb
and then the ecb can lend those dollars
to deutsche bank so that's the swap line
it's a swap of euros for dollars where
europe just basically creates euros and
then post them as collateral to borrow
dollars from the fed if one of those two
currencies uh strengthens aggressively
against the other or depreciates
aggressively against the other uh does
that break the swap line are there
issues there it doesn't really because
you know the the movement is not
material enough to these guys are not
borrowing on leverage they're borrowing
you know full amount so let's say you
borrow 100 million and then the currency
moves five percent against you you owe
105 million back to the european central
bank that's not going to that's not
going to break anything absolutely and
so when you think about some of these
issues um is the
central bank of the united states and
other countries they just have to
continue to take on more debt they have
to continue to create more money uh and
it's pretty much just like a race to see
who can do it the least uh fast in some
way it is because if you think about the
way that you know united states in 30
trillion of debt
and uh financial crisis you know every
two to five to ten years each time
another crisis happens the government
has to borrow trillions of dollars the
trillions of dollars that it has to
borrow isn't it immediately available in
the market in terms of the bar the
lending source so the fed comes in and
monetizes it the reason that the fed
does that and the reason that the
government does that first of all the
government does it because they don't
want to get voted out so it's easy to
just say here's the stimulus here's the
next stimulus we've seen that now 15
years straight uh non-stop stimulus then
the fed
looks at the inflation rate historically
not today but inflation rate at one
point something percent two percent and
in decline and they look at a declining
inflation rate as a danger zone for them
because when
prices go down a a credit system starts
to collapse right credit needs expansion
because you always have you always have
to borrow
to
pay back your debt you know you have to
roll the debt so if deflation happens
it's the fed's number one fear
and so that's why they do qe that's why
they lower interest rates is because
they are they are fearful of deflation
and so they'll do anything they can to
prevent that and so in that way we have
to assume that
the policy from government and fed will
be stimulative now
looking at this year specifically i
think we're gonna have to wait
for the next stimulative episode to
begin i think that the fed views eight
percent inflation as maybe equally
dangerous so they have to keep going on
rate hikes
i do not think we're gonna see qe
anytime soon we're actually seeing the
opposite we're seeing qt the fed is
shrinking its balance sheet it's raising
interest rates so it's actually
strengthening the dollar as an asset as
a global asset relative to other
currencies and so we'll see that and we
we might see risk asset weakness on the
back of that
but i think the fed's most important
goal right now is bringing inflation
down the federal reserve uh is
intentionally crashing stock prices
right it may not be their stated uh but
that is part of uh raising interest
rates in conducting this quantitative
tightening is there a point where they
wave a white flag because there is so
much pain in the asset price uh
drawdowns yes and we won't be able to
see it directly in the stock market
right you have to look at the treasury
curve you have to look at yields to know
when that's going to happen okay so
let's say for example stocks go down
another 20 percent and we look over at
the treasury market and yields haven't
really come down yet
what that means is that the market is
not pricing in
fed cuts
yet right they're still looking at fed
hikes
but let's say the stock market now goes
down 50
and two-year treasury yields go from 275
back down to one percent
well the fed funds rate's at one percent
right now
that means the treasury market is saying
hey fed you're done
you're done here stop hiking
it's over so i wrote a piece for my sub
stack a couple weeks ago about how
we're let's compare the federal funds
rate and the two-year treasury yield
when the treasury yield falls below the
fed funds rate the fed has to be done
because it's the market selling the fed
you're done right now
twos are at two and three-quarter
percent
fed funds at one percent 80 90 basis
points it'll be at uh you know 1.4 by by
june 15th when they raise another 50
basis points so we'll have
fed funds at one and a half and twos
north of two and a half so there's a
a lot of room for the fed to keep hiking
who moves does the two-year move down or
does the fed funds rate move up so both
are going to both have been happening so
uh the fed funds rate has been moving up
it'll continue to move up right they're
going to hike again on june 15th
the two-year yield peaked at around
just under three percent and
went actually all the way below two and
a half percent it's back up to two and
three quarter percent right now so
yields
have
shown that they are topping
now
so
now is basically when we have to watch
carefully when does the when does the
yield come crashing below
the fed funds rate and right now there
is no crash in yields yields are showing
uh topping formation but they're again
up up quite a bit this week so
we have to be we have to always watch
the market and look at what the market
is telling us and i look at the
difference between two year yields and
fed funds as the best indicator in terms
of how much runway does the fed have
left to hike rates why don't they just
go right to two and a half percent
why don't they just say forget this 50
basis point thing we're telling you guys
we're going to two and a half let's just
go there tomorrow they could have done
that pomp they could have a couple
months ago they could have said hey
we're gonna we're gonna go right to one
and a half percent we're gonna go right
to two percent
and to be honest they probably should
have moved faster because now the slower
that they go
the more likely it is that risk assets
bleed out and that
yields come back down and basically put
the fed in its place and say you're done
so the reason why they're not going to
do it on june 15th let's say is because
the fed
does this thing where they signal right
so they job on the market they get the
market to price in what they say is
going to happen once the market gets
there then they stop talking and their
goal is to not disrupt
the market so you know short-term
interest rate traders that are trading
three-month bills or you know
fed funds rate looking three to six
months out
they are
doing those trades under the assumption
that the fed will do what it says
in the next three to six months we know
that what whatever the fed says they're
gonna do in two years is [ __ ] right
they're not just they're we we can't
trust what they're gonna say what what
they're gonna do what this what they say
they're gonna do looking one to two
years out
but quite differently we can pretty much
completely trust what they're gonna say
that they're gonna do within the next
three to six months time horizon so
basically about six months ago they say
we're going to start raising rates 50
basis points at a time every meeting and
so the market starts to price that in
and they don't want to upset that so the
the fed balance sheet was 900 billion in
2008 2009 uh crossed over 9 trillion
about 12 years later uh almost 14 years
later um
they're now connecting quantitative
tightening they've tried one time before
and pretty much gave up you know almost
immediately and was like hey this isn't
working
why should we believe that they'll be
able to be successful now so the last
period of quantitative tightening went
on for
a couple years and
they did have to reverse it why do why
do i think that qt is going to happen
again this time well there's a couple
reasons
number one
the feds reverse repo
operation that they do
this is a facility that they allow banks
to come park money back at the fed in a
risk-free way
there are two trillion dollars
on balance held back at the fed right
now that basically means that the 9
trillion that they have outstanding is 2
trillion too much
so they're looking at that repo balance
at 2 trillion and saying oh we've we
actually went 2 trillion too far
that balance didn't exist during the
last period of qe
where uh sorry
during the last period of qt
there was you know about 100 to 400
billion parked at the fed overnight
during 2016
era and it would spike to 400 billion
only on
march 31st june 30th when
the banks are looking to window dress
their balance sheet and they they need
to put money somewhere so they just put
it back at the fed
the it's very different this time around
we have 2 trillion it's it stayed at 2
trillion for several months now it's
been growing in size the balance it's
just an indicator that there are way too
many reserves in the system
and the fed looks at that reserve
balance plus inflation at eight percent
and they say look raising rates is not
going to be enough we have to double
tighten we have to raise rates and we
have to shrink the balance sheet and
we're going to continue to do that now
it's it can't last forever right we've
talked about the dynamics that it does
in a credit system you do have to keep
growing the amount of debt in the system
but that doesn't mean it can't
have periods of contraction that last
for an extended period of time so i'm
looking for the fed to continue to raise
rates over the next several months i'm
looking for them to continue the balance
sheet runoff for at least the next year
and um the fed will cave on hikes before
they cave on balance sheet um but again
it's going to depend on
how dramatic the next financial crisis
or stock market crashes i think global
debt to gdp is like 350 percent u.s is
like 130. um everyone always talks about
the debt it's debt debt debt uh but
obviously uh there's a gdp component of
it as well
why can't we just grow our way out of it
we are um there's record tax receipts we
just heard last week record tax receipts
so gdp and revenue to the government are
at record levels and with inflation at
eight percent it's also going to be a
boost to the nominal gdp growth as and
and so there are you know a couple ways
to historically get rid of debt one is
to default and one is to inflate and so
the us
or grow right so the us is taking a
combination of growth and inflation as a
way out i'm not saying that
you know debt to gdp is going to go
under 100 because of this but it does
give the united states government
decades potentially a runway here we
still are the best country in the nation
i mean sorry the best country in the
world for business
for entrepreneurship look at bitcoin
finding its home in the u.s after 14
years like finally it's here all the
businesses are being built here forget
new york for a second you know we're
looking at
bitcoin business the first bitcoin ipo
uh you know
several investment funds that are
marketing bitcoin we have
big multinational corporations that are
accepting bitcoin here in the united
states so
it's very bullish for the u.s to have
bitcoin here and um
i think that the united states
government has a lot of runway here in
terms of being at 130 percent uh debt to
gdp do you think it can go under 100
that would be tough to to imagine here
with you know gdp at 20 something and
and debt at 30 something um i see the
u.s government not really able to get
into surplus right and only in a surplus
will you stop the nominal debt from
going up
um so i don't i don't see the u.s
getting to a healthy fiscal situation to
the point where we could get back down
below 100
the federal reserve obviously is run by
uh humans uh like you and i uh they're
valuable um there's the fomc where
people go into a conference room uh they
have a lot of data there's a lot of
smart people uh they try hard they are
well-intentioned but they're still human
and it's a human-led monetary policy
that allows them to uh manipulate
interest rates asset purchase balance
sheets et cetera as we've been
discussing uh bitcoin is the exact
opposite and i usually tell people it's
an automated central bank it's got a
programmatic monetary policy set it and
basically you can forget it because it's
not changing um what are the pros and
cons of a programmatic monetary policy
and do you think that uh that
programmatic monetary policy means that
bitcoin could rise to become a new
global reserve currency
so what's the con to
an algorithmic monetary policy the con
is that
you can't step in
to
save any individual or entity in any
scenario
now
is that really a con or is that just um
the other side of having
a monetary policy that's set in stone i
think that's why
people like bitcoin because they view it
as a more equitable
situation
the federal reserve obviously has
discretionary monetary policy and when
do they exercise that discretion when
their buddies are in trouble right when
the banks are in trouble
and they say we have to do something
about it well is that fair to the rest
of the world
it isn't fair just because the fed says
that hey if we
bail out the banks stocks won't go down
as much then if stocks go back up we
have a wealth effect in which people
that own stocks
spend more money into the economy and
that will create jobs is that going to
make a bartender feel better
no i mean no it's not and so
discretionary monetary policy is to
help people in certain situations and i
think the people have viewed the way
that the fed has done it as inequitable
it's not like they have another choice
right they don't have all these
different tools they can use they can
lower rates raise rates or do qe that's
basically all they have so they decided
to do it let's lower rates and do qe and
that's what we have to do but when it
comes to bitcoin
we don't have those human beings
involved so we can trust that there will
be no bailout under any circumstance
and if that is something that you
and the public view as more equitable
more fair
it is possible that they go in that
direction
and
i do believe that yes that does make
bitcoin positioned to be a world reserve
a world reserve currency
it already is by the way because enough
people keep it as their world as their
reserve currency so it already has
started but how many how many people
right tens of millions perhaps
far shy of a billion far shy of seven
billion so
how long will it take to get to a
billion people that think of bitcoin as
their reserve currency many years but i
do believe that we'll get there when you
think about that um
not bailing people out is definitely one
piece i also think of this idea that um
uh in the human-led variable monetary
policy the world has to um or i'm sorry
the monetary policy has to conform to
the world good times there's certain
monetary policy when bad times come then
the monetary policy conforms and changes
kind of we're talking about the bailouts
et cetera
with a fixed monetary policy or
programmatic monetary policy
uh the world has to conform to the
monetary policy right like the
it's a very different thing what it does
it changes behaviors
and one of the components that i don't
hear a lot of people talking about but
it feels important is when you have a
variable monetary policy it's really
hard to plan years decades in advance
when you have a programmatic monetary
policy it's very easy because you know
exactly what's going to happen right
we're talking about hey we can trust the
fed and what they say in three to six
months but we can't trust even two years
let alone you know 10 20 years from now
and so by moving to a fixed monetary
policy does that drastically increase
the ability for people to make long-term
investments and drive r d and innovation
and actually end up being like a
tailwind in some way sure so i'll answer
that by
starting with this idea that i don't
believe
bitcoin is replacing the dollar as the
world reserve currency i believe the two
coexist for decades and decades to come
then what that presents is a choice for
businesses do we want to denominate our
balance sheet in bitcoin or dollars and
that choice will be driven by
what they want as their own monetary
policy
do they want something that responds to
the times or do they want something
that's fixed and i believe that choice
will be present for companies for
countries as well
over the coming decades and we'll see
that
okay this company wants to
plan for the future without having the
fed affect
what they're doing now
if they have shareholders that are
dollar-denominated but they're doing
everything in bitcoin they're going to
have to factor that in and maybe hedge
out their bitcoin volatility back to
dollars just so they can do activity in
bitcoin so it is really important to
you know remind ourselves that bitcoin
and the dollar system will both coexist
and we'll see that choice presented i
think that's a good thing and i know
people get mad about that but
living through the collapse of the
global reserve currency um especially if
it happens suddenly
would be catastrophic to
many people that you love care about
interact with on a day-to-day basis
and uh in some way
um
having a zero-sum view of the world of
it's this or that uh ends up one not
being how the world works uh but two is
it doesn't allow for the building of the
parachute right um and if you think
about there's a lot of currencies that
are very very bad very undisciplined
they still exist now it's pretty well
understood they suck right no one's
going to use them
but they still exist and so for our
currency to actually die
it is uh
very difficult for that to play out and
so i think your point about like
we actually should want coexistence and
give people choice uh which brings me
this idea of central bank digital
currencies which are really the same
monetary policy just kind of a
technology wrapper if you will uh what's
their role in the future
yeah
central bank digital currencies will
change the way that the fed does things
um it is just a different wrapper it's
basically changing the rails of the
financial system from the old way of fax
machines and swift wires to
uh you know a more digital digitally
native
maybe not
using a chain of blocks but using a
shared excel spreadsheet that some
people call distributed ledger that type
of thing it will modernize the system in
some ways so that's a good thing for
the fed for banking technology and all
that
but in my book layered money one of my
predictions was that
cbdc's will be used as a fiscal tool as
well as a monetary policy tool
to give universal basic income to people
so in the way that we all received
pandemic
payments whether we asked for them or
not during the pandemic from the
treasury department i feel that in the
future we will get
fedcoin
into our banking wallet whether it's
your wells fargo app or treasury
department app
um and you'll just get the money right
away and that will be your direct
payment there'll be no check in the mail
from the treasury
um there might not even be qe anymore
you'll just get money in your wallet fed
coins here you go and that's the
stimulus
so
the way that we're going in terms of
observing
universal base basic income both in the
us and europe
it tells me that
that is a possible direction of
where cbdc's will go and for that to
happen you will need legislation
and so this is one of the things i've
been thinking about recently is that
this might take a lot of time right now
we have a situation in which the
executive branch and the legislative
branch are not able to get anything done
and that will get even worse after
november
and will last another couple years of of
gridlock
and then we'll get into the 2024
election and then maybe bitcoin will be
in the campaign maybe cbdc will be in
the campaign
um
but it's hard to imagine
congress and the president coming
together
on a new federal reserve act amendment
because that's what you would need to do
fedcoin and to do ubi through a fedcoin
so the more i'm thinking about it the
longer i think it's going to take for
the fed to have their own coin
but let's watch europe what let's watch
the ecb and how quick they are to
do a digital euro and have universal
basic income
going directly to european citizens
you wrote a book layered money uh you've
got it there with you um
why did you write the book and what will
people learn yeah this one is for you
thank you
um
from golden dollars to bitcoin and
central bank digital currencies which is
really it's a a
history of money to some degree it is
the first uh it's ten chapters this is a
short book the first uh six chapters are
about the history of gold and the dollar
system
and um
and then we get into bitcoin and uh you
know how bitcoin represents i believe
the future of money
um you know i wrote it to give people an
intro to bitcoin and i did believe that
if you need a proper intro to bitcoin
the first 60 of the book cannot use the
word bitcoin
and you know sephidines did something
similar
in the bitcoin standard he didn't really
mention bitcoin until the back you know
one-third of the book
and um
but really i wanted to tell a story of
money so the biggest thing i did
was try to figure out when to start the
story
and i didn't know whether to start it 5
000 years ago
1 000 years ago 75 years ago
and i ended up you know reading a lot
about the renaissance era monetary
system and discovered the fiorino de oro
the gold florin which was a coin issued
by the florentine mint in 1252 and it
had an unchanged weight in purity for
over 300 years and
you know the light bulbs started going
off i'm like this is
bitcoin and and even when i was reading
how the florin was used as a
denomination across europe at the time
where administrative salaries were done
in florin no matter what country it was
uh international business trades were
done in florin no matter what country it
was it reminded me of the dollar that
the dollar today is used as the currency
between brazil and mexico
why it's not brazilian it's not mexican
but it is the currency of choice because
it's achieved that
um consensus and consensus is another
word that we think about a lot in
bitcoin the dollar has this strong
consensus where does that come from and
i try to trace the story back and back
and back into time and
also trying to demonstrate that bitcoin
is achieving a consensus that mirrors
gold
and
that makes bitcoin a once in
not a generation but a once in a
millennium
or once in a you know
a species type of innovation
and um i wrote it in a way that my mom
and dad could pick up
uh the the
men and women on the trading desk
sitting next to me could pick up or
friends
it could pick up and so i tried to write
it in a way that didn't lose the reader
i had my wife and my dad help me say hey
it's too thick here it's you gotta
simplify it to try to make it accessible
for as many people as possible and uh
gotten incredible feedback so far thank
you everyone for reading the book
and uh we're up to 15 languages now um
about half of them are live
another half are on the way and uh
spanish is coming out june 22nd
very excited about that
and uh so yeah it's a lot a lot
happening with layered money from golden
dollars to bitcoin and central bank
digital currencies i just put the link
in the chat for anyone who uh who wants
to uh to go buy the book um you have a
course uh that you're going to be
teaching at usc uh you already have one
but you're gonna have a second one
bitcoin digital assets what are people
gonna learn there yeah so um
in my bitcoin course at usc i'm going to
start with the white paper so i'm gonna
show that this came from a an academic
paper that was put out in 2008
by satoshi nakamoto and you know show
them the origin of this then we're going
to go right into layered money do a
monetary history
and then we're going to come out and
we're going to learn some of the
fundamentals of bitcoin so there's going
to be a homework assignment download a
wallet send it download a lightning
wallet send a transaction i'll give
everyone 100 sats in the class do your
lightning transactions practice write
down a seat learn what learn how to use
bitcoin basically then we'll get into
some of the more nitty gritty stuff
about bitcoin uh one of the teach i'm
going one of the things i'm going to
teach is fidelity's bitcoin first paper
where we present
okay i tell a quick story um
about this course and getting it
approved
the department made a suggestion to me
that i named the course cryptocurrency
after i after i proposed uh the course
and you know i
politely
and adamantly said no
because this is not about cryptocurrency
this is about bitcoin
and cryptocurrency is an echo boom of
bitcoin i will address that that exists
but i'll also address it from a bitcoin
first perspective
that okay these things might exist but
why
have have i taken a bitcoin
only approach why is the course named
bitcoin and not crypto and so i'm going
to be teaching that throughout the
course we're also going to do some
on-chain stuff um i think it'll be one
of the first
courses in the country at a major
institution that teaches on chain
on-chain analysis as something that is a
new fundamental way to observe and value
the asset
you had dylan on talking about on-chain
it's an important field and so um
ark wrote a great paper about it but i
haven't decided exactly what material
i'm going to i'm going to use
um
or which superstar
on-chain analyst i'm going to have fly
out to la and guest lecture for my for
my students but um yeah it's going be
bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin that's what
we're gonna teach uh i do i do plan to
teach the
treasury department's paper on fedcoin
and because we have to understand the
implications in other areas of the
economy but it's not a crypto course
it's a bitcoin course we're going to
teach bitcoin teach people how to use
bitcoin teach about the lightning
network teach about
blockchain data that comes from bitcoin
software and just really give students
an overall understanding of what bitcoin
is yeah that's awesome um you also i
think are going to talk today about uh
you're going to do a course with sailor
academy uh talk a little bit about this
yes so this is uh something i haven't
shared publicly yet so um several months
ago
i got in touch with michael saylor who
read layered money and
loved it and uh basically
you know he invited me or we agreed to
teach layered money at sailor academy so
in a few weeks that will go live
on sailor academy's website the course
is called monetary history
and it is based off of the book layered
money so
we will go through the history of money
the introduction of bitcoin and look at
the future of the monetary system
i'm incredibly excited about this course
to go live it's of course going to be
free for everyone and the content of
layered money um will be there for the
students
and um
i'm excited to promote it and and all
that kind of stuff so uh sailor academy
course called monetary history look for
that in a couple a couple weeks yeah it
i think that the history of money is so
important people to understand because
it makes it's so much more obvious what
are the pros and cons of various assets
that are used as currency today
absolutely and and and you know sailor
academy the administrators over there
told me that
um i think it's stefan lavera's course
the bitcoin course is their number one
most attended course
on the academy what does that mean
people want to know about this stuff and
of course with michael saylor being such
a vocal advocate i'm sure he's driving
students to learn about bitcoin but um
this is going to be part of their
bitcoin offering absolutely yeah and
then you have a newsletter that you
write and you're going to be publishing
videos on youtube as well what are you
doing there sure so uh my sub stack
publication is called the bitcoin layer
we've talked about a couple of the
pieces today already and uh just decided
to a couple months ago
take the next step
in bitcoin education and launch a
youtube channel by the same name so
people can go to
thebitcoinlayer.com
to find uh the link to my new youtube
channel as well as the link to my
substack publication both are called the
bitcoin layer and we are going to be
doing educational videos about all
things bitcoin and macro so i want to do
videos about explaining the lightning
network is going to be my first video
i'm going to do videos on
how does the fed conduct monetary policy
what the hell is repo
how do interest rates work what does my
global macroeconomic framework look like
what do i do in the morning when i come
in and i'm checking price
what am i checking the price of how am i
looking at all that kind of stuff so
this is my
this is my effort to
give
an educational research
on everything that i've ever known
finance and business-wise to the world
the substance publication
is a lot more timely research and
analysis as we're going through
fed hikes and all that kind of stuff the
youtube is going to take a step back
it's not going to be as timely of
material it's not going to cover
what the fed is doing this week but it's
going to explain how does the fed do
what it does and give these videos you
know a little bit more shelf life so
that people can come in hopefully in a
year's time from now come into my
channel and um get a master's in finance
yeah there are uh some of the best
teachers in the world are on youtube not
in in classrooms you may be the first to
do both
[Laughter]
right is beyond both uh where can we
send people to find you on the internet
yeah so people can go to
thebitcoinlayer.com or layeredmoney.com
it's the same website um please
subscribe to the youtube channel please
subscribe to the sub stack i do plenty
of free content on the substack
publication as well i do have a paid
service there for
more specific and in-depth research and
analysis
layered money on amazon all the books
are on the website sorry all the links
to the
books are on the website um the
audiobook has done incredibly well it's
the most popular format and uh links to
other languages of layered money are
also on the website
awesome i could talk to you literally
forever uh i i think that your
combination of uh monetary history your
understanding of uh kind of how the fed
works and then obviously bitcoin is uh
uh very rare um you're doing a lot uh
one of our sponsors is eight sleep what
is your sleep schedule or like your
personal routine every day sure so um
i it depends if i'm writing or not okay
um we have a four-year-old daughter and
uh her sleep schedule is about
7 30 p.m to about 5 30 a.m
and uh
and sometimes it's five sometimes it's 4
45
but that means that our day starts early
in our house we're up at five every day
and we're getting we're getting the day
started um and then i do try to get to
bed by 9 00 to 10 p.m um
on nights that i'm not writing and on
nights that i'm writing um sleep goes
out the window and i make up for it the
next day or throughout the rest of the
week because
with a four-year-old daughter in the
house
and a lot of things going on obviously i
have you know
contracts i have things you know
teaching to do um finding time to do the
deep thinking in an absolutely quiet
environment
it's it's almost impossible
when the sun is out for me so at about 9
00 p.m on nights that i'm writing this
is maybe twice a week
maybe more during the book it was six
six nights a week um but yeah from about
9 00 p.m to
12 or 1 a.m i'm writing
that's awesome i love it um
follow you on twitter
read the book if you didn't read the
book yet you're missing out let's go uh
and we'll have to do this again in the
future this is absolutely fantastic
thank you so much for coming thanks paul
appreciate it dude